um so for you man going from starting
out independently
you're on RCA right no Warner Warner
okay uh going through the major label
situation where it felt like they kind
of didn't know what to do with you or it
just kind of felt like obviously it
didn't work out how you probably had
wanted it
I'll tell you right now it was it was
just
um I got to do what I wanted to do right
but they also had to approve certain
things and um I wasn't feeling it you
know when not when I got off Warner I
was able to make music with who I wanted
to make music for anything blah blah
blah like but
when I was on on Warner I was like I
want to do a CL this is a perfect song
for this person I want to get this
record to this person I have someone
that wants to make it and they would
like
give their personal personal opinions
right you know um I even I just have so
many crazy like stories I was only on
the label for two years but it was just
like you got all these people that don't
really know music right that want to
tell you how to make music and who you
should make music with and how you
should create music right you know what
I mean and it just wasn't wasn't my vibe
because you're not in there with all
musicians you're in there with business
people suit and ties people who know
like finance and all that kind of stuff
but when it comes to the music like
there's no answers to this you know what
I realized is a lot of these people in
these buildings and these major labels
their number one objective is to not get
fired that's all I care about yeah so
they're like how can I not get fired
they want to avoid risk right exactly
right so their whole thought process is
okay I don't want to get fired because I
got a [ __ ] Mortgage in these [ __ ]
kids I gotta feed and a side [ __ ] and
all this other [ __ ] going on and artists
are rich wrist and I have this yeah I
have this artist I want to push him to
do a song with I'm playing the numbers
game uh so-and-so's got a [ __ ] viral
hit or it's hot right now let me try to
push that feature to happen even if it's
not organic yeah or you might be like I
would rather do this because it makes
sense and it sounds good and oh that's
I've I've got the credits they when I
was in Warner I mean no shade but I was
they they tried to push me to do so many
songs with these artists who's the most
random artists they try to do right um
I don't know just random like EDM kind
of I don't even remember the names like
yo you should do a song with [ __ ]
crazy upload yeah and then I I was me by
the way that'd be kind of hard
marshmallows fire yeah it just it just
has to it's just two bad examples it has
to feel right yeah it has to feel right
but I but I've been in the room and I've
sat with like the president and I've
been like oh you know we I want to do
this song or we're thinking about we
want to get this song done with there
was one time I was like I want to get
this song done with uh juice world and
they're like oh juice world like wow we
don't think that's like necessary or we
don't think that's uh early tour you
know it was early super early and
they're like oh we don't think and I was
like it makes sense like the sad music
kind of thing that would have been crazy
they're like oh no well we think you
know we should kind of turn that side uh
around and we should do something more
up-tempo you know they always want the
up-tempo kind of thing I'm just like
that's not me that's not what I'm trying
to do like I'm trying to you know I have
this vision and they're like oh well
this song and these songs are doing good
it's just too much like
like analysis from people who aren't
really like
taking in like well they're just worried
about losing their job yeah that's how
it is and that's what it but sometimes
they think they know just they want to
put numbers on the wall bro but they
think they know based off previous
numbers and there's always going to be
something everything's always evolving
yeah exactly yeah for sure they go off
the past so now right now they're going
off like Tick Tock and that and you know
it has to be like this it has to be like
this because this is doing good but
what's after that you know that Tick
Tock thing is is uh the best and worst
thing that's probably ever happened oh
music because it's like it's dope
because you get discovered and if you
know there's people who've gotten
discovered on Tick Tock that are
actually really talented and yeah but
then there's other [ __ ] where it's like
these labels are just signing
it's like and then you hear the whole
song and you're like
what is this
but it's giving more power to
Independent Artists so at the same time
right because people you know you have a
hit song and you're just like [ __ ] I
Don't Need No Labels it also is good if
you're on it and you're doing the right
[ __ ] you're creating the right content
you're engaging with your fans it's a
like it's a way to pop your [ __ ] right
you know like uh someone who kind of had
a similar career path in terms of like
dealing with major labels starting off
independent ending up independent again
is like Snow the Product yeah she was on
Atlantic forever she's dope and they
[ __ ] fumbled that whole situation
then she got off and then she went did a
[ __ ] freestyle that went viral and
yeah and then it got Grammy nominated
I've seen it I've seen it I've known
snow for
for a long time years five six plus
years she's a she's a beast and she
really got that she got the Latin side
two or two so she got a wild thing yeah
yeah crazy she's super dope underrated
underrated super underrated